he is my friend from fox sports in the
athletic covering college action college
football and it's season coming up he is
our friend Bruce Feldman how are you
Bruce I'm good to be on with you too sir
so I give you the floor I'm what what is
going on in the college football world
right now that everybody is talking
about I imagine it's the possibility of
not having a season walk me through that
yeah I think it depends who you talk to
and what parts of the country you talk
to people depending on how hard the
coronaviruses really hit their area you
know from a lot of people I've talked to
especially you know around FCC country I
think they're very optimistic that there
will be a season and it can start on
time I think when you talk to some
people maybe in the Midwest and
certainly on the west coast I think
they're probably a little more maybe I
don't know skeptical is probably too
strong a word but I think they're more
of the let's see where this is where we
are a month from now two months from now
I think they're probably a little more
guarded with it
but I think also you know you got to
keep in mind like a month from now is
still a while away I mean so I think
people are waiting to see okay is this
going to ease up as the country starts
to open up more and go I don't see go
back to normal but but starts to go back
out is are we gonna have another
outbreak are the numbers gonna go up
significantly are the numbers gonna go
up you know depending on how much more
widespread the testing is I think that's
one of the things that a lot of people
on the education side of this are
waiting to see especially is what's
gonna happen with with the testing
because in order to have games think we
have to have a lot more rigid testing in
place from the people I've talked to you
think that that needs to happen whether
it's fans in the sand or
not there's just a lot of uncertainty
and and I've seen a couple my colleague
put bringing us up and I think it's true
sometimes the answer of I don't know is
probably the most valid one because
right now I think there's a lot of
people especially if you're on the on
the coaching side you're like all right
we're gonna prepare mentally and get
things in place as best we can as if the
seasons gonna start on time because it's
easier to reevaluate from that
standpoint than it is to act like hey
we're just gonna we're just gonna kick
the can down the road and hope something
better comes along at the Stargate 2021
well what about the idea Bruce that you
know that there's got to be kids on
college campuses in order to have a
football season and we've heard some
college commissioner's of conferences
say this is a student athlete sport
scoff all you want but if there are no
kids on campuses and there's remote
learning we're not having a season is
that I guess is that still the operative
sense or there could be fractioning
saying certain teams in the big 12 don't
want to do it that's fine we can have a
big seven or a big six for the year I
walk me through that right now yeah I
think that issue is becomes kind of a
moving target and it changes for people
hosted by the day but I think that
people fluctuate on on it and the
leaders of the sport remember this is
already a fractured sport in college
football in terms of more than probably
any other that's in the mainstream
because there is no commissioner there
is a group of conference commissioners
but I'll give you this scenario which is
let's say that the numbers are not as as
devastating in the SEC footprint and
look Louisiana's gotten hit very hard by
it especially Orleans but let's say that
a month from now the numbers are not as
devastating as they are maybe in some
parts of the Midwest and certainly in
the Northeast then did the FCC say look
we're going to sit this out
like everybody else is intending to even
though we feel like we have I don't want
to say that they have this handle
because that's that's probably not the
right way to frame it but even if
they're looking at say you know what we
think this is something that can be
managed and if we take as much
precautions as as we can because the
ramifications of not having a college
football season it's financially
devastating to colleges and definitely
college athletics
so rather if we feel like we're in a
position where we can have a season even
if it's even if it's just a conference
season even if it's eight games and not
not a full 12 games as well you know if
there isn't some version of a bowl
structure in place I think it'd be hard
for them from that standpoint to go yeah
we're going to sit this out just like
everybody else
in unison because we're talking about
hundreds of thousands of dollars and
hundreds of millions of dollars and and
you know you're talking about millions
and millions of dollars in the financial
potential that it has to wreck
many of these colleges they're not just
their athletic ruins but also the
businesses around these colleges I think
that this is not it's not an easy
decision for people to make and I think
one thing just from you know taking a
step back on it I think the thing that
you know a lot of us whether were in the
media or whether we're in the middle of
the sport whether we're fans whoever I
don't think it's necessarily just a
black and white thing where you can say
you know what they're they're thinking
of having a season that means they don't
believe in science or they don't believe
in X Y or Z or if they think that it's
right now it's the situation is
cataclysmic that okay this is people who
don't consider the other things I think
for most people it's not a so black and
white I think there are there are really
levels to this and that's why I think
it's it's so complicated you know a lot
of people to to track it this thing is
moving absolutely
we'll know if a few freezes coach of the
year then Liberty is the only team that
was playing this fall against each other
you know and then when it all comes down
to it though Bruce what do you think the
the eventualities of this is you were to
talk about you know revenues then
certain schools that have the the cash
that could do it certain schools that
need the cash must do it you know you
kind of came up with the idea of this
will be science-based
we're not seeing that a lot in society
today so my question for you on that
front is is it possible that we end up
seeing you know the haves play football
and a half knots not is that a
possibility this fall I mean I think
it's possible I think what you got to
keep in mind is you know as things start
to open back up we're not talking about
like is this gonna are we gonna see
dramatic spikes you know a day later I
think it's something that people are
gonna have to monitor I also think you
know towards the bigger issue of this I
think for decision makers and for a lot
of people though I think the numbers as
devastating as they are and what do we
had a 80,000 deaths in the country at
this point almost that I think the thing
that it becomes even more real to them
you know if the numbers don't when it
hits somebody very close to them and
it's that thing that changes it you know
I think that for a lot of people who
watch this they're like they saw Rudy
Gobert and they saw Tom Hanks and Rita
Wilson and and they've seen people who
they know uh but then they've seen them
either you know recover from it or
whatnot I think when they see if they
started to see people on the teams they
root for really you know struggling with
this I think that would that would
change for a lot of people again I think
what we're talking about different than
opening up some businesses
as opposed to having football which is a
sport which is every day of the week you
are around 100-150 other guys and the
potential for there I mean this isn't as
much as like you know Mike Gundy went on
you know had his comments a month or so
ago by the 22 year old it's not just 18
to 22 year olds I mean there's guys on
on most coaching staffs who are 50 60
years old I don't know you know there's
probably a handful of them also who have
some pre-existing conditions I think
it's it's just it's complicated and
again I think that as they try to
monitor what we can what they can manage
and what they feel is something that
they can can can kind of deal with both
mentally as well as from the from the
science aspect of it I think this is
such a moving target for a lot of people
you know we talk about science people
are like you know while this model was
wrong and that model is wrong it's not
like talking about the weather forecast
right so there's so many variables that
go into it including some human you
don't human variables that go into it
and I think that you know as the
leadership and quotes around college
football tries to chart this I think
it's you know you're gonna see you know
there's a university president you may
see ad concentrators make a statement on
a Tuesday and then it you know it could
be invalidated or maybe it'll be parsed
in the wrong way because we've seen a
lot of that and I just think that right
now we're in this weird echo chamber as
people try to make sense of it and right
now I know I don't think anybody's gonna
have you know they could say we're
definitely going to play we feel
confident we're gonna play a season and
it could all change you know three weeks
from now just like I think if somebody
says hey we're not gonna it doesn't look
very good well who knows maybe maybe
things will change it's just like I said
it's not like just a weather forecast I
think there's so many variables that go
into this that said leave it really up
in the air probably more up in the air
than then most people are used to
thinking it's just like you know what
let's let's see where it goes reader
king of NBC Sports and
and football morning in America spoke to
dr. Anthony Fauci about the NFL seasons
possibility and we'll have Peter on in
about a half an hour from now a little
bit more with Bruce Feldman from Fox
Sports and and also the athletic here on
the Rich Eisen show what did my coach do
on Friday that people might have missed
because Lots was going on UFC was coming
back and the weekend was upon us and and
he sent out a letter to the football
community I gave you the floor on that
person what and the the ripple in the
pond after that well III think he's
trying to try to think big picture at
least in terms of he's talked a lot
about some other issues whether it's
when kids can transfer but also I think
in this time it was like basically who
could be cleared and when to leave early
for the NFL I was just sitting out you
having to wait three years from your
high school class I do want to jump in
here for those who may not know we're
referring to Jim Harbaugh of Michigan
when I say my coach so I just need I
don't want to assume everybody knew what
I was talking about so I'll give you
there sorry don't mean to interrupt I
just wanted to get in there yeah I think
that I mean look it's an interesting
idea I think there's a lot of things
that are probably more complex than they
get you know the one-time transfer
exemption is an example of how this is
more complicated and when it's relates
to to the scholarships and everything
else involved I mean right now the NCAA
and it's been this way for a while he's
been operating under a 25 cap limit of
scholarships you get a year so even if
your program is not at 85 that's not
that relevant to to how this works let's
say you're your program you lost a bunch
of kids early who decided to leave and
they became seventh round picks or sixth
round picks or whatever first round
picks
and you're down to 67 scholarships you
don't just get to get back up to 85 you
only get 25 and that is the thing more
than any other that I think is you know
driving what a lot of coaches maybe not
Jim Harbaugh are concerned about because
you cannot replace the ones and I think
how that relates and people get they
okay that's just coaches the
like they're protecting their own
self-interests while that is true you
also got to keep in mind there are not
going to be places for kids who transfer
to land because if there's not 25 if
there's not a couple of vacancies less
than the 25 spots and a lot of schools
rarely have more than like one or two
after signing day happens there's no
scholarships for them to go to and so
what happens and it's happened a lot
with the portal already is players end
up thinking oh well this school offered
me out of high school yeah but that was
out of high school they filled those
spots probably they may not have room
for you and so a lot of times kids
announced they're leaving they just they
they essentially give up their
scholarships and they end up with
nowhere I did a big story on the
athletic last week about this very thing
and I mean it is a fraction of people in
power five it might be like the ACC I
think there was over a hundred kids who
flew laughs you know about 10% of them
actually got FBS scholarships after they
left it's just so I think infuriating
this goes to also Jim's open letter I
think it's one thing just to put that
out there as a billboard and it's
obviously Jim Harbaugh is gonna get a
lot of attention I'm sure there's plenty
of Ohio State fans going yeah he wants
all our great players to leave because
we have the kind of kids who can leave
you know earlier than you know his kids
I think that's you know that's awful
health well and good of a rivalry but I
think the practical piece of it about
there needs to be other if you're gonna
do that they need to figure out some
other legislation to have offset so it's
not like there's a road to nowhere for
people who are leaving and there's no
scholarship opportunity for them to get
Bruce Feldman of Fox Sports in the
athletic and your latest piece kind of
bring it all together of this whole
what's old is new again world and trying
to use it as a prison for the current
sports scene like the last stance in a
way you spoke to Reggie Bush about the
name and likeness name image and
likeness new world that's coming to
college football what a Reggie you have
to say
Reggie's perspective was fascinating we
talked for about a week back and forth
about this subject and he's of the mind
and obviously he got into a lot of hot
water with the NCAA his alma mater got
devastating sanctions lost 30
scholarships to your bowl ban and really
Reggie Bush could have made so much more
I'll be according to the the experts
I've talked to you for the story
projected what Reggie Bush would have
made if he played now which is ten times
what anybody else you know Trevor
Lawrence Joe Burrell any other star
would have made this past year under
this rule and even if you use Reggie
Bush's actual time frame which was
2004-2005 he still would have made they
projected two to three million dollars a
year based on his earning potential
which would be I don't know ten times
what the NCAA was alleging that he and
his family would have gotten no work to
have gotten in benefits and so when he
looks at this he and he told me is like
look I made some mistakes through this
I'm not going to say I didn't and
there's things he regretted about it but
he said you know my situation had to
happen for people to look back and say
all right this is a wrong system because
remember when what the money that people
were making again offered off of college
athletes when it comes to the high end
of the food chain
that's pretty staggering so we were
talking about somebody who could have
made two to three million dollars
missing even before social media with
pretty eye-opening and I think he said a
lot of times in this country we are very
reactive
we're not proactive and it's he said
sometimes people look back and go wait a
minute what were we thinking why was
this the rule or anything like the NCAA
has fought this at every turn
and he's happy that for now he said I'm
glad that thousands of kids will end up
benefiting from this even though
obviously it was it was a real mess for
him and his family and and certainly for
us see in the wait let's started over
video
back in the day this one now this I mean
I think this is this whole thing gets
really complicated it goes down a
slippery slope in a hurry and I think
you know to tie back to all the other
anti L stuff they're worried about third
party people you're worried about
transfer third party people I mean
there's just it's it's all kind of
connected and the reason why this and
this is a little dimension in a story
the reason why this ni L stuff is so is
so hard for the NCA is because let's say
you know you're a prominent a lot of
your school you want to have us have
some your star quarterback come to your
son's birthday party you you could do it
for 50 grand you could do it for a
hundred grand normally it wouldn't
matter but because there's a recruiting
component tied to college athletics
right that's where the NCAA is trying to
police it and that's what's going to
come into the crosshairs of the cup of
Congress who are going to say wait a
minute
that's not free market value if you're
capping it and you're limiting it so
it's going to get very messy of the NCAA
tries to sort this out going forward and
the Reggie Bush story is a real good
example sure of how it can get really
messy well I guess the the video game
stuff I meant is that that's that that's
how the name and image and likeness
stuff got started you know with the
O'Bannon jetsetter for in college
basketball but I guess what I'm what it
just put a button on this whole
conversation here is it we have no idea
what college sports gonna look like post
Kovan 19 we have no idea how many
programs are still gonna be existing
depending on how long this goes and if
fall sports does in fact exist and we
may we may see a separation between
power five conferences and the rest of
right and the rest of college athletics
and the potential you know parting of
the ways we're cover five starts their
own stuff outside of the NCAA I mean
things you I'm reading and hearing so
much stuff based on what might happen in
the next six eight twelve months it's
crazy we have no idea what the world is
going to look like Bruce
we don't and I think the thing that just
you know people probably need to keep in
mind here is we're talking about
hundreds of millions of dollars as it
relates to it and there's there are not
easy answers to this and I think as as
people get really further down the road
on what's happening with the virus as we
get closer to the football college
football season I just think that you
know you got to keep in mind that there
is really fractured leadership here and
that's that's kind of a recipe for a lot
of the things you just outlined
potentially happening I mean the the
margins are very slim
for some of these programs who are not
Alabama or LSU or Michigan or Ohio State
that's just very different world they
live in
Bruce you the man I hope everybody's
happy and healthy and safe in your world
same to you rich at the time so he's
good talk always Bruce that's Bruce
Feldman check out his new piece he spoke
to Reggie Bush it's a great read on the
athletic and then obviously you'll be
back on the sidelines if there is a
sidelines to get back on this fall on
Fox Sports hey you watched all the way
to the end thanks for that watch more
right here